in early 1945 both the USSR and the East
and the U.S led allies in the west were
racing to capture Berlin as you'll know
the USSR got there first and took the
city in April of that year yet after the
war was over bullion didn't simply
remain a part of the ussr's occupation
zone or even East Germany but was itself
also divided between the Victorious
Powers which raises the question why why
did the Soviet Union hand over West
Berlin to the allies when it already
controlled it so it won't surprise you
to know that Berlin being the capital of
Germany meant that it had a symbolic
status to the Victorious Powers as such
when both sides were discussing how
Germany would be divided it was agreed
that Berlin would also be shared
everyone had agreed to this because
nobody knew who would get to Bull in
first and so making sure everybody got a
slice of it seemed fairest that said
Stalin wasn't exactly famous for being a
man of his word and so when Soviet
troops captured the city he had to
choose to hand most of it over to the
Western allies and his reasons for doing
so were actually quite simple first of
all there was still a war going on in
the East Japan was still warring away
and so both the Western allies and the
USSR needed to get along the Soviet
unions are a massive opportunity in
controlling massive amounts of territory
in China Korea and also potentially
Japan and thus alienating Washington
London and Paris wasn't going to make
the post-war recognition of any changes
easier as such Stalin honored his
previous agreements because handing over
a chunk of a city in return for a chunk
of a continent seemed like a good trade
secondly Stalin believed that the
division of Berlin was only a temporary
measure the Allies were simply doing so
to show unity and it was an
inevitability that cooler heads would
Prevail and Berlin would be reunited the
plan was never to divide Germany up
permanently and Stalin had hoped that a
reunited Germany would soon become
communist and by extension under his
control as such handing over West Berlin
wasn't seen as a concession but as a
Goodwill gesture to the Soviet Union's
Partners furthermore given that West
Berlin was well within the ussr's
occupation Zone Stalin knew that he
could simply starve the Western powers
out with the stroke of a pen when it
became clear that Germany's division was
going to become permanent and that the
West Was going to incorporate their
Germany into an anti-soviet Bloc he
closed the west of the city off and the
U.S knew that without having the ability
to bring in food they'd have to leave or
at least they would have had Stalin not
made one tactical blunder he forgot the
sky existed as a result of the blockade
the U.S and Royal Air Forces air-dropped
food and supplies into Berlin for just
under a year until Stalin relented and
it was at this point that Stalin had
realized his mistake Western occupation
of Berlin wasn't just symbolic of
Germany's defeat but also of their
commitment to resisting the USSR and
without any way of removing the West
without full-scale War the plan was to
make staying there as difficult as
possible this was done by holding up
shipments and making the red tape
aggressively hard to navigate this
ultimately didn't work which is why in
1958 Stalin's successor Nikita
Khrushchev issued an ultimatum to the
West leave Berlin or will do something
the Ally said No and when the deadline
passed and nothing happened well that
was it and eventually the USSR just sort
of had to accept that it made a mistake
handing over half of Berlin because the
Western Powers weren't going anywhere I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patreon supporters
James bizzinet Kelly moneymaker Sky
Chappelle call show wolf kotoitska Adam
Stalter Jerry lambdin Alex Schwinn
Jordan Longley Marcus arsner rod D
Martin why in hockey Spencer Lightfoot
Captain psydog Marvin Castle boogly
Wiggly kimun Yoon Winston K wood Aaron
the white the mcquopter Miss izet Maggie
paxkowski Gustav Swann Anthony Beckett
Coppertone shewenin spinning three
plates Charles the first and words about
books podcast